foreign
[Music]
I'm playing again today because my ego
was bruised by a weatherman from Erie
Pennsylvania I know why Tom's mad he
wasn't voted in the top ten of the
sexiest bald men alive that's what I'm
here I took that [__] personally man I
think you're too much of a [__] [__]
I'm not kidding Ball's wet wait was that
in that's a
after months of constant [__] talking
speculation and anticipation it appears
we finally have a conclusion in the Tom
Segura vs Erie Pennsylvania weatherman
beef if you're not sure what we're
talking about right now we posted a
video a few months back recapping the
entire situation involving Tom and the
weatherman so watch that real quick and
then come back and don't forget to come
back please I essentially made a comment
about okay you know instead of me being
on your podcast let's go play a game of
basketball one-on-one I wear my jeans
high and tight but then he was like if I
played you I would destroy you and I
just you know I took that [__]
personally man so the game took place in
Austin Texas on February 24th with the
footage being uploaded to YouTube last
week the rules were simple make it take
it ones and twos game to 21. if you want
to come to Austin Texas to play
one-on-one not again I will donate fifty
thousand dollars to the charity of your
choice if you win but if I win I have to
keep my Instagram open for a year and I
have to make an apology video that he he
approves of which means there's going to
be notes going into this matchup I was
very confident in Tom he had way more to
lose in this situation so the
motivation's got to be through the roof
plus he has the home court advantage and
appears to be in way better shape but
obviously we all remember what happened
the last time Tom Segura played
basketball ended up in the hospital
[Music]
I tore my patellar tendon I shattered my
arm
I couldn't do anything for months I had
to do rehab and it was a disaster yeah I
[__] myself up real bad now before we
get into what happened during the game
there's something the weatherman said in
this video that made this entire feud
between him and Tom seemed like just a
big misunderstanding earlier in that
newscast we had actually ran a story
about the sexiest bald man alive and so
when the two news anchors tossed it to
me I was like look I know why Tom's mad
he wasn't voted in the top 10 of the
sexiest bald men alive that's what I'm
here that was kind of like my yeah I'm
gonna punch back at this guy and that is
what ended up on the podcast uh oh you
did not David Walter 87 check your
social media in about an hour pal
I think all of us including Tom got so
annoyed with this guy in the first place
because it seemed like the sexiest bald
man joke with some cringy random attempt
at roasting Tom that barely made any
sense but David explaining that they had
just run a story about the sexy bald man
competition that had so much context
that now it's an innocent not even that
bad callback joke on their own broadcast
as far as the game goes it started off
with all the pure domination Tom
predicted he got to his spots early and
often his shot looked good and he jumped
out to a quick 20-9 lead it really
seemed like Tom was cruising to an easy
win but that's exactly when the madness
started the ref who ended up being one
of the more entertaining parts of this
whole ordeal made a horrible call that
gave David Walter the ball and the
momentum David's ball what David's ball
you got to be kidding black and white
says I'm not kidding that ref is corrupt
but he also high-fived me during the
game which is super unethical David took
this gift from The Ref and ripped off
eight straight buckets each one more
wild than the next these were some Hail
Mary's just chucking the ball at the
hoop and it was working the comeback was
in full effect and the main mommies were
in panic mode until Tom was able to
finally get a stop and go to work down
low for the win
as a ball game folks
look I don't think suicide is something
to joke about but if I had lost him I
would have killed myself overall it was
pretty cool to watch David Walter
finally Embrace Tom in the ymh fans lean
into some of these jokes play in this
game and accept these challenges he
posted the agreed-upon apology video
that was full of all the ymh lingo he's
picked up from his comment section the
past few months I'd love to talk about
Hawaii but I have some important things
to say I'd like to take this opportunity
to apologize to Tom seguro he's a very
smart and sexy bald man and personally I
think he should be at the top of the
sexiest bald man alive list he's got
that beautiful mouth and he's built in
such a way my brother didn't believe me
at first but he believes me now I said I
destroy Tom on the basketball court and
I didn't he proved himself to be a
worthy opponent I'd like to think we've
gained respect for each other both
personally and on the court congrats Tom
you beat me as far as the rematch goes
if you want to do it again you better
believe me I'm coming up in May
personally I wish they posted a full
version of this game somewhere I
actually wanted to see these guys hoop
not just watch a cut up of all their
made baskets but I guess that's probably
better for the YouTube algorithm also I
reached out to David Walter many times
to come on this show and do an interview
for all of us with no response which
kind of makes me mad because he
literally said in his apology video that
he'd love to meet us I'd like to tell
every Tom and ymh fan this you're
welcome to my page and at my house
literally I can't give them a physical
address because of security reasons but
Lord knows I'd love to meet you the
comedy Mothership has been open for two
weeks now and continues to be the
coolest thing to ever exist since our
video last week detailing the
mothership's first kill Tony dope [__]
just keeps happening at Joe Rogan's new
club they've officially opened both
rooms and it seems like every single
night there's a different comedy Legend
casually dropping by this club including
Dave Chappelle Shane Gillis Pete
Davidson Pauly Shore and so many more
this place has been doing everything
right and still somehow it feels like
it's not even close to its final form or
full potential yet if you're a fan of
Comedy it's really hard to find anything
not to like about this place except for
maybe the scarce amount of tickets
available but that's kind of unavoidable
or at least to be expected when the host
of The Biggest podcast on Earth opens up
his own club and stocks it with the
funniest people he can find also the
mothership has made it very clear they
do not accept resale tickets so if
you're thinking about trying to attend a
show please be careful out there guest
spots from last week your mom's house
did not have have a guest two bears one
cave was Bert and Adam DeVine kill Tony
tonight is with Tim Dylan and Roseanne
Barr flagrant had on Ben van kirkwick
Phil Hanley was the guest on stavy's
world Bert Kreischer was on Matt and
Shane's secret podcast Bert was also on
the honest Papa's hour and Mark Norman
was on the blocks podcast one time I
fell asleep with a girl uh spooning on a
couch so I just was peeing like into her
ass basically and the couch was Leather
So it pooled oh it was brutal I never I
never went back but I gotta say I if
it's the kind of couch I think it was
you're it was fine it luckily it was a
boozy time it's it's New Orleans it's
the South it's college so it wasn't that
crazy but it was still brutal no I'm
sure a lot of people were peeing into
other people on love seats now R Kelly
this past weekend with the Yvonne had on
George Kittle The Joe Rogan Experience
talked with Shane Gillis whiskey ginger
head on Jimmy Carr Miss Pat was on the
Honeydew Josh Peck was on bad friends
Neil Brennan was on we might be drunk
Kevin Neal in was on the Harland Highway
and for all this Julie's out there
busting with the boys head on Shane
Gillis and Bert Kreischer as far as new
stand-up comedy specials that are out
right now or coming out soon Bert
Kreischer Razzle Dazzle came out last
week on Netflix which is why it works on
this current podcast run we've also been
talking about this for a while now but
big Jay oakerson dog belly is coming to
YouTube on April 5th three weeks after
that John Mulaney is dropping his latest
special titled Baby J on Netflix Russell
Brand has a new special on Rumble and
Jeremiah Watkins daddy comes out on
YouTube tomorrow
and some joke world news real quick to
wrap up the end of this video we have a
special announcement coming later this
week that I think you guys are going to
be really excited for it's interactive
it's fun it's gonna be great so just
keep an eye out for that later this week
we're going to have some sort of
announcement exciting fun like I just
said other than that thank you so much
for watching this episode of the joke
World comedy news update every single
Monday bringing you all the news you
need to know from your favorite
comedians your favorite podcast yada
yada yada thank you for watching
subscribe if you want this is the end of
the video
[Music]
thank you